an interesting study came out of Holland
and you're not gonna believe this but it
is true
women do cry more than men and we've got
some info for you men cry for an average
of two to three minutes compared to 6
minutes for women men are less likely to
experience extreme crying that's the big
waterworks the hysterics that you see on
the TV they're all the time
females are more likely to cry for more
than an hour while females cry between
30 to 60 4 times a year
men only cry between 6 to 17 times per
year so we've got a quote from ayodhya
who is the editor of girl talk she says
I think if the media had a more balanced
perspective on human emotions and didn't
pigeonhole women and men perhaps the
survey would have different results
there aren't enough emotional males on
television or in the media for men to
relate to there's a segregated view of
what is accepted as masculine and
feminine the media it's because of the
media so I think that's actually a
pretty sound argument right there there
may be some genetic or biological or
evolutionary reasons as well no Molly
you're not with me you think you think
this is purely just kind of the way
media frames things men have to be
strong you can't see man crying but you
can see that yeah yeah I mean I don't
think that there's any really solid
proof that like women's tear ducts are
shallower or that like we're just more
emotionally unstable naturally I swear
right the there's two social things that
play here one is that this entire study
is self-reported
right so like it's self-reported women
are gonna be more comfortable admitting
that they cry more right in addition the
fact they probably do cry more because
of social constructs like that and I
think that ahsha's point is great and
Asha is amazing as a person and a really
really intelligent woman who has great
things to say about everything but she I
think hits on something really really
really prescient which is that men even
still in the media and we're in 2015 and
we have a black president and we have
you know all of these these things that
have evolved for us over the last couple
decades still there aren't really men
crying anywhere like American sniper or
there's a moment because you've just
killed however many people and you're
like having PTSD that's okay to cry
right oh not like not very much the only
other thing I can think of a man crying
or at least not even in a movie is John
Boehner who does cries when he gives
speeches and you know he
you know when he's accepted things and
awards and things he gets very emotional
and we all make fun of him for it right
or at least all the comedians do and
then pretty much everybody does and yet
if it was a woman we would think it was
a tender moment or something so that
does go to just our expectations right
of men and women well that's at that
moment where Hillary Clinton finally got
emotional and everyone said that turned
around her you know ability to run as a
presidential candidate so we finally saw
like this math come down and saw her
have some emotions right when John
Boehner cries what oh you [ __ ] you know
so he's a little bit of a double
standard there but I mean it look I
think the biggest point is what you
maybe said think about self reporting
that was one of my first question was
how much do we trust self reporting and
rich do we expect women are inherently
more okay with saying they pride and men
are more likely to disguise the fact
that they've cried so I think maybe this
statistics might be a little bit off on
this that B's that I'm telling you right
now I cry literally every day
okay so never cry every time all right
well I want to know when the last time
you two cried and then I'll tell you
mine so I think we have yours already
but waterworks oh I want tear has to be
coming out of guys not just teared up um
so I made this promise myself when I was
13 and I had had my first kiss and I
never called that I would never cry
about a guy again ever
and maybe it says something about my
life being like a little too blissful
that like I cry really about anything
okay
I cried in movies sometimes the last
time it was like waterworks though I was
on a plane I'm like a plane movie
watcher crier and it doesn't matter what
movie it is I will like always tear up
so it was like 27 dresses or PS I love
you or like some not even sad movie and
I was crying my eyes and it just got
okay last night I cried this morning
what were you crying about this shoulder
surgery on Monday two days ago I had
shoulder surgery and I was trying to
actually get dressed and right now the
arm hurts so much I'm honestly not
taking any painkillers right now and I
remain alert and articulate
I need to bring a button-down shirt
today but I actually attempted to put
something on that wasn't to my arm came
completely out and it hurt so much that
I started to cry and then I got so
frustrated about it that it was an
emotional crime it wasn't a cry okay so
that that I think is really interesting
because a guy like I know if I if I stub
my toe or bash than I ever hurt myself
like I wouldn't cry from that there
would just be that that emotion wouldn't
be in the little box of things that I
would pull out I'd be screaming and I'd
be pissed and angry but that but that so
a girl might cry for pain no I usually
actually don't cry for pain I cried for
the frustration that's associated with
the pain so this morning even though my
arm hurts so much that's not why I was
crying I was crying so like god dammit I
can't get in this dress and I get it but
I'm hungry in a new coffee I like this I
cried for like I cried for like all of
civilization and you know I got cried
for all things since the beginning of
time already five times a day before I
got here is what I'm saying so it didn't
necessarily have to do the fact that my
arm hurt that was just a that was just
the you know what is it the trigger hing
thing that made me cry for everything
that's ever happened out in the Sun of
the moon yeah
alright well I want you to cry by the
end of this segment so I'll tell you -
crying stories what my last cry was
about a year and a half ago when my
grandma was dying and we were all saying
goodbye to her on her deathbed
standard stuff and we actually had a
really beautiful moment and and I cried
the other one involves my other grandma
when she was dying this is about five
years ago and we knew that they were
gonna have to pull the plug and I
watched the movie click did you ever see
the Adam Sandler movie yeah like so I
wrote I watched it thinking that it was
going to be like an over the top Adam
Sandler ridiculous comedy but if you
watch the movie it's actually pretty
touching and beyond basically movies
that just [ __ ] with you you're a funny
movie he gets this remote control where
he then skipped through and fast
forwards through his whole life and I
was watching that knowing that they were
about to pull the plug on my grandma and
how fast life goes and all this and I I
mean lost for an hour like uncontrolled
could not stop that would be an
acceptable thing to self-report crying
about you know so that just kind of now
I've cried over I've cried over the last
five Adam Sandler movies because they're
all terrible they're all terrible I
think there's also like something
interesting happening to were like yeah
we're all movie like we've cried movies
all three of us here has
anyone cried about the don't even care
about Charlie Hebdo did anyone cry about
see that's thing is I cry about stuff
unrelated to meet you what do you want
that's right eyes are like watch
humanity every day which sounds like
I'll just see the news and all of a
sudden to start crying or I'll see
something positive and inspiring and
start crying I cry all the time I have
no problem saying that I think I'm a
person with an iron will like people are
like you're a tough lady to me so I I
have no problem it's not like I feel
like oh I'm crying it makes me some I
don't care I cracked a lot
alright well Jenn made it through this
segment without crying but are you
crying right now when's the last time
you cried let us know in the comments
right down below